last time we left off we saw the Slavic
tribes going into the European Plain and
possibly coming into contact with the
Germanic and hooning tribes now with the
downfall of the Roman Empire being
inevitable the migration period began as
the Germanic tribes were moving out of
their area to settle in the former Roman
lands and their homes falling into
obscurity the Slavic tribes gradually
started to expand throughout Eastern
Europe it is most likely that was during
this expansion time that the division
between the Slavic tribes started to
occur depending on where the tribes went
and Western southern and eastern
divisions we see today were largely in
place by the middle of the 6th century
today we will follow the early journey
of the Western Slavic people settling in
Central Europe it didn't take long for
them to be right on the border of the
Germanic kingdoms expanding as far west
as today's Lubich in north and possibly
Salzburg in south here the Western
Slavic people became known to the
Germans as to whence deriving from the
word vanetti which was the name given to
one of the Slavic tribes by procopius
this word Hauer is very confusing
because even though early on it was used
mostly just where the Western Slavs it
became to describe at one point or
another also the southern Slavs the ruse
or just Slavs in general as to Western
Slavs ran out of area to move into they
found themselves face-to-face with the
Germanic kingdoms and with their Eastern
flag now being raided by mysterious
incoming nomadic people called the Avars
they started to establish small tribal
political entities as to protect
themselves from all these new enemies it
was at this point that the Byzantine
Empire wasn't too happy with the
barbaric South Slavs along with their
eminences of some Germanic tribes
encroaching on their border and so they
paid of the Avars to conquer the lands
north of the Danube de vars did so and
were successful in establishing a canid
in the Pannonian Basin subjugating many
different people including some Western
southern Eastern Slavic tribes Germanic
tribes and Romanians who are now
established in the area of our start to
hold raids into the surrounding kingdoms
including the Byzantine Empire the Avars
also tried to conquer the northwestern
Slavic lands but these up until now
became closer to connected economically
and politically to the Frankish Kingdom
and so with the help of the Franks the
western and northern tribes of West
Slavs managed to stave off devourer
armies but as such remained under
Frankish influence which wasn't that bad
as
when compared to the avars who regularly
pillage Slavic towns stolen rape Slavic
woman and for Slavic men to fight in
their Wars due to this the Slavic
population of the Carpathian plain
became very sparse but all that will
change in 623 with the arrival of sama
on the Slavic political stage what do we
know about him is that he was a Frankish
merchant most likely originating from
the area of today's Belgium or France as
a merchant he started selling Frankish
weapons to the Slavs who needed them for
their frequent rebellions against the
avars
how he himself got embroiled and these
survelliance is unknown however we know
for sure that he proved to be a very
skilled military commander when leading
the Slavs against the avars
his newfound fame amongst the Slavic
tribes resulted in his Democratic
appointment as the king of the trap
somewhere within today's Moravia from
there someone went on to solidify his
rule amongst the Western Slavs freeing
the Slavic tribes on the day of our rule
and claiming control over the tribes
under the Frankish sphere of influence
the first to retaliate these actions
were the Avars but someone managed to
easily defeat him and then quickly turn
his attention to the Franks who managed
to muster up a formidable force under
the leadership of Dagobert the first
come again proved to be a skilled
commander and managed to feed the
Frankish forces at will guessed his book
with his borders now secured the reign
of salmon within the first known Western
Slavic Kingdom was exceptional he
expanded the borders form new trade
routes forged alliances and overall
managed to bring stability into the
chaotic Western Slavic lives yet summer
wasn't a feudal king like you would see
in other parts of Western Europe he was
in power because he was appointed by the
traps to be in power as such when some
who died in 658 with no clear successor
the kingdom literally fell apart
overnight and the Franks and Huaraz came
back to reclaim their former lands
however something changed the Franks
regained more direct power over the
Western West Slavic tribes and the Avars
started to be slowly assimilated into
the overwhelmingly large Islamic
population there are accounts of the
Avars adopting Slavic customs and the
main language of the other can aid
became Slavic but despite all of that
there was still a division between the
ruling of our class and the Slavs
it was also during this time that many
new nomadic people invaded through the
Carpathians into the Danubian Basin most
notably the bull guards who managed to
be repelled and had to settle in the
Byzantine control Sofia minor from there
they launched freak
raids into the of our territory slowly
chipping away at the can eight Holdings
but the Avars themselves didn't remain
idle and we're launching rates of their
own and to the surrounding territories
including the ones under the Frankish
influence and in 788 into the Frankish
Kingdom itself this was the last straw
for the Franks and chowmein himself
oversaw the offensive into the of our
kingdom and in several campaigns managed
to speed the avars for good and
subjugate the Slavic tribes that used to
be under our control
whatever Last Remnant says we're left of
the avars was subsequently conquered by
the Bulgarian Empire with the canid gone
many of the Slavic people now within the
two empires regularly raided the
remaining of our settlements on account
of their poor treatment under their rule
but the Franks now in control of the
West and the Bulgarians of the south we
have to talk about the Slavic tribes the
north east of the West Slavic lands
which will later form Poland we don't
know much about these tribes because
Slavs had no writing and these traps and
no or a very little contact with the
people that did as such we can only
speculate about what happened in these
lands prior to the formation of the
Polish Kingdom however it is unlikely
that much happened anyways as they
largely didn't have to protect
themselves from outside influences
unlike the border tribes we are also
going to look at the northwest and focus
on the short stories of the Western
Slavic tribes of öbut writes valetti and
sorbs also known as the polly bein Slavs
or German Slavs as they lived in the
lands of today's Germany while boat
rides are interesting because despite
their Slavic culture and origin they
acted very much Germanic they had a
system resembling more of the
western-style feudalism than a Slavic
tribal system they were close allies of
the Franks fighting against the Saxon
and the Danes and later becoming part of
the HRE
in fact the German noble line of Dukes
and Grand Dukes of Mecklenburg which
lasted till 1918 was started by not a
chairman but a Slavic a betrayed Prince
pretty slow on the other hand the
variety which lived south and west of
the Alba traits were also interesting
they didn't really have a single unified
political entity and were largely
controlled by the Franks but they did
name many notable places in eastern
Germany for example Berlin lastly let's
look at the source who like to valetti
never really had any independent Kingdom
and the little autonomy they did have
was usually politically and economically
overshadowed by the bigger neighboring
kingdoms and that autonomy will
eventually
also phased as they will be absorbed
into Saxony but regardless of all of
that swabs managed to survive to this
day and are the last remaining Polly
being slaves living in today's chairmen
II going back to the bigger political
stage the Avars are gone and the freqs
control most of the western slavic
tribes one of which the principality of
Moravia quickly gained lots of power as
it laid right in the middle of the
ancient amber Road Trading amber from
the Baltic Sea to northern Italy as such
the region became quite rich and many
medieval fortifications sprang up around
the area in eight hundred twenty s Moy
mere the first managed to solidify his
power in Moravia and annexed the
neighboring principality of Nitra with
his power in the region now secured he
tried to exploit the civil war in East
Francia and declare independence from
the Frankish rule however that didn't
turn out so well as Louis the German
managed to defeat Moy mirror and appoint
maurice nephew Rostislav the first as a
puppet Prince of Moravia but the rest
yourself just as his uncle had different
plans than to be a puppet of the Franks
and an 853 rebel he was further aided by
the fact that the king of West Francia
bribed the bull guards to help the
Moravians fight against East Francia so
the Moravian Bvlgari alliance along with
another Frankish rebel army started to
attack Frankish lance and Malita
chairmen yet again had to march in
Moravian lands but the rest you saw
unlike his uncle knew that the strength
of Moravia is whether its formidable
medieval fortifications therefore deploy
defensive tactic ambushing the Frankish
forces and then quickly retreating to
the castles rusty Slavs tactic proved
effective and Louie had to withdraw from
Moravia appointing his son cattlemen to
protect the eastern border from any
further Moravian attacks but Karl man
had a different idea he allied himself
with rusty Slav and tried to use the
alliance to take down his father this
didn't end well for Caliban as Lewis
forces managed to defeat his army and
carlomon had no choice but to surrender
for the next 20 years or so tensions
between Moravia and the Franks remained
high with the Franks never being able to
fully subjugate rusty Slavs lands and
Moravia became the only known
continuously independent Western Slavic
entity at that time it was during this
time that the rostislav tried to
centralize his power and his and
surrounding lands one of the ways he
tried to do this was by reducing the
power of the Frankish priests within
Moravia this is because by now most of
Moravia was largely Christianized
our older priests leading the masses
were franks using the latin scriptures i
see so i wanted to get rid of this
Frankish influence and so he sent a
letter to the Pope asking him to send
priests who were well versed in the
slavic language and could educate the
population unlike the current non slavic
speaking Frankish priests the pope did a
reply us arrest assault her into the
eastern church asking for the same thing
they replied by sending two missionaries
well-versed in the south slavic dialect
spoken in here
the brothers st. cyril and methodius
when they arrived in more obvious serial
created the first ever written alphabet
for the slovak language called glug-glug
la Holika a precursor to today Sir Alec
the brothers hastily started to
translate the latin scriptures in
Moravia into Holika but the Frankish
core G in Moravia realized this was a
big threat to their control in the area
and quickly dispatched letters to Louie
and Pope to help them get rid of this
threat the latter however surprisingly
invited the two brothers to Rome and
Pope had G and the second approved the
Slavic translation of the Scriptures
cereal subsequently died but Methodius
was appointed as the Bishop of the
Moravian lands and surrounding Slavic
areas nonetheless despite the Pope's
approval Frankish clergy and muy were
not having it and CARLMAN presumably to
get on his dad's good side captured
methodius and plotted with rostislav
sneb you swat a bloke to capture st
sloth they were successful and presented
rostislav to louie the german in 970
Rapanui
orders Rostislav was blinded and
imprisoned where he later died for his
help in capturing rostislav sweat the
book was allowed to rule the eastern
lands of Moravia but had to swear
loyalty to the Franks the rest of
malaria was divided up between two
Frankish counts to add to all of this
right at the start of sweat applix rain
sweat Epoque was imprisoned by Carolyn
on some dubious accounts and as the
Moravian nobility presumes what the book
was dead they appointed a new ruler
slava mean cattleman later on decided
that's what the book wasn't guilty and
released him afterwards presumably to
mend the alliance he took his army to
help sweat a blue tape back Moravia but
during this campaign so attaboy betrayed
Karl man joined the Moravian forces with
Slav Amir and destroyed the Frankish
army along with two Frankish counts
controlling the rest of Moravia
now in possession of the whole kingdom
the long struggle between the estream
cranks and the Moravian started up yet
again while these campaigns were
happening Pope John the eighth was
trying to broker a peace between the two
kingdoms and restore Methodius as the
Bishop of Moravia he was successful in
973 and finally a peace deal was struck
between the Franks and the Moravian sand
Methodius was allowed to return with the
Frankish borders now secured so at the
plug underwent an expansionist policy
expanding south into the Pannonian Basin
west bohemia and north into poland here
we get one of the earliest written
accounts about poland and the defeat of
the pagan ruler in southern poland by a
tabloid as everything seemed to be going
well two major problems started to occur
which will shape the history of the
Western Slavs to this day first was the
internal power struggle between
Methodius appropriate of the hala holy
liturgy and sweater plug a believer of
the Latin liturgy the latter created the
Archdiocese of Nitra and appointed the
Frankish Bishop witching this meant that
even though methodius was still the head
Bishop of Hall of Moravia after his
death the successor would be rich Inc
this happened in 995 and subsequently
reaching with the help of Swatow book in
Rome expelled all Methodius as followers
and reinstated the Latin liturgy
overhalla holic Methodius as followers
will become important in the next
episode but for now it is important to
understand that the Western Slavs used
the Latin rather than Cyrillic alphabet
today partly because of sweaty boys
expulsion of Methodius and reinstatement
of Latin liturgy second was the
encroachment on the Pannonian Basin of
yet again another nomadic tribe this
time called the Hungarians their raids
in tomorrow via an east francia
proceeded so at a plug but it was during
sweater pox rain that the Hungarians
started to play more in dominant
political role in Central Europe for
example in 981 so I hope we can
intertwine and the politics and
rebellions within East Francia this time
also the bull guards tried to fighting
as they were hoping to use the confusion
to gain some land from either franc or
your Moravian it was during this time
that the Hungarians were paid off to
raid the Lower Austria Herod is unknown
by whom as the Moravians accused the
bull gars and vice versa this fighting
between the Franks and Marat viens would
continue until swoop Luke's death in
1894 after which his eldest son mehmed
ii succeeded the throne but due to the
internal strife
and continued Frankish aggression
maravilla lost most of its land
including Bohemia and Pannonia it was
right after Frankish occupation that the
Hungarian tribes came into full force to
settle into Pannonian Basin claiming
that the land was sold to them by sweat
a bloke when he was still alive which
seems very unlikely unless the Franks
gave up the land as they were in no
position to fight the full Hungarian
forces for the next 12 years two
remaining Moravian sand Eastern francs
combined their forces to fight off the
aggressive Hungarians but eventually
they lost a 19-7 at the Battle of
Pressburg today's Bratislava the battle
was the last straw for Moravia and its
lands get subjugated by the Principality
of Bohemia and the Hungarian Kingdom it
is also interesting to note here the
quick occupancy of the Hungarians within
the Pannonian Basin and the fast former
Slavic population assimilation into the
Hungarian tribes but if you consider the
fact that the basin wasn't very
populated in the first place due to the
actions of the Avars and then later
retaliation by the Slavs and make sense
for the Hungarian settlement to have
happened so fast
but now the polybius and Czechs firmly
under German control learning how to say
numbers incorrectly the Slovaks
wondering where it all went wrong
under the Hungarian control the
political vacuum paved the way for the
new Western Slavic kingdom to start
emerging in northern Europe first
undeniable ruler of the polish Mischka
dynasty was made for the first although
we have ever writing about his ancestors
it has been disproven and as I mentioned
before we don't know much about Poland
prior to me ask oh so looking at Mishka
more closely under his early rule Poland
resembled the kind of tribal Union like
Samos Kingdom was a couple hundred years
ago and as such did not have much unity
it was partly due to this that Mishka
decided to adopt Christianity along with
the western style of governing copying
the Bohemian Kingdom and marrying into
the Bohemian royal family his wife da
Brava would later on die and he would go
on to marry into the Saxon royal family
but not before she bore him two children
mishka's reign was mostly spend on
solidifying his rule within the
neighboring tribes and kingdoms
providing a more stable line of
succession and connecting Poland with
the rest of Europe creating a Polish
kingdom that will dominate the later
half of the Western Slavic medieval
history
[Music]
this is where I will conclude my Olli
Western Slavic history video my next
episode will look at the early history
of the southern Slavs and we will find
out what happened to sound the Methodius
his followers if you enjoyed this video
and would like to see more please
consider subscribing and supporting me
on patreon until next time my name is
Emma lazer
[Music]